what's happening please my name's run
right
I'm Jerry bet that threw you off okay so
we just saw the hateful eight
Tarantino's eighth film coincidence of
the title I think they not
anyway the hateful eight we're gonna be
doing a spoiler talk about the film
because I really feel like a lot of the
criticisms really in the details of the
movie but beyond the criticism but even
to explain why there's parts of it that
I love I have to go into detail about
I've grown so we'll see what we can tell
you without spoiling anything the cast
[ __ ] fantastic
any what's good what's cool about the
characters is that they are what
Tarantino set out to do which was make
sure none of them are like a mohawk
they're not like characters you can
really root for like I was talking with
Veronica on the way back and I was like
man this is just a really nasty film
where these characters are they're
enjoyable and they're likable in their
own way but they're technically not good
people you know they're the difference
between enjoyable and like Oh likable is
like a lot of them are fun to watch but
none of them are technically likable
people because they've all done
something terrible either before the
events of the movie or during the events
of the movie and in most cases both what
I love is that okay there's this book
called save the cat if you guys have
heard about that what they talked about
with dislikable characters in this
screenwriting book and I noticed almost
every movie does the trick of save the
cat they'll take okay this is a bad
character we're gonna focus on is them
as the main and protagonist of the story
let's have him do something nice in the
beginning that way we know without where
we can root for him you know
you establish a moral code so that we
can identify yeah this movie doesn't do
that well yeah and it plays with your
perceptions of the characters because
it'll introduce certain people certain
ways and then you know some characters
early on some characters much later on
you'll find out that they're not so
savory after all who you're clinging to
kind of changes over time and as part of
the fun of this movie is sort of as
things unfold figuring out who you
dislike the least you can still be
onboard with and how that allegiance
change
that's it like I didn't walk out of it
going who do I like the most the
question that I was asking was who is
the least bad out of everyone if and the
spoiler review I will reveal who I think
is the least bad and why and I feel like
different people probably will get
different answers totally and I love
that this film is a debate that you're
gonna have it's called the hateful eight
they are so easy to hate on good I could
see people hating this movie because of
how nasty the characters are like
they're not people at all and the film
is [ __ ] violent [ __ ] it is when it
gets there it has some very violent
moments and there's a but there's always
a violent undertone to everything yes
nasty yes not so nasty like there's
still lots of humor like it's still
snappy it still has rhythm and there are
characters who are still charming and
fun to watch so it's not like you know
watching I don't know what a good
example is but it's not like watching
something that's like in your face ugly
the whole time you know what it kinda
reminded me of you remember an
inglorious basterds if you guys have
seen the movie where the Basterds and
Michael Fassbender are posing in the pub
that was like a 20 minute sequence and
it was like a build up sequence yeah it
seemed like and that's kind of what I
feel like this movie was acting like
where it was affects its action build up
like it's primarily dialogue in the
first like hour and a half of the film
it's a cool build up to what's gonna
come because this movie if you watch is
it only in the 70 millimeter version
when we saw it I don't know if it's in
every theater but there was an
intermission oh it's noise okay so it's
not in every theater yeah there's an
intermission and the intermission
brilliant to have because halfway
through that film I saw everyone talking
about it in terms of what's gonna happen
next they think or how are you feeling
about the film so far what do you like
what are you not like like you're you're
getting opinions from everyone based off
the intermission of just the first half
just so much happens well it's a cool
thing about Tarantino specifically and
you know some of his cohorts you know
everybody knows Tarantino know his films
and knows film history and he's giving
us something that is older that we
you know don't get any more like that
the 70-millimeter Roadshow cut of this
movie at least there are no trailers
there's just an overture at the
beginning of I presume Ennio Morricone
ease music and then it launches into the
movie then there's intermission like you
would see with the old epics or you know
you know old movies like Ben Hur and
stuff like that you know yeah or or the
old westerns some of them that's a
really cool thing to get now then we
don't get anymore so that was just a
dazzling thing - and go do it really
plays out like a play yeah like I could
totally see this being on the stage one
day okay Tarantino talked about possibly
doing that oh definitely I mean though
mostly takes place in one location two
locations I guess you'd call it but
they're all kind of contained and it's a
lot of people yeah you know I was
thinking like they're just certain
scenes that get cut out or just staged
different yeah what you gotta do is
light a different side of the stage yeah
one thing that we were talking about was
I felt I wouldn't consider it one of my
favorite Tarantino films in terms of
just my initial feeling that might
change cuz this is a few how did you
absorb over time I left this an hour ago
and it's dense like it doesn't feel like
it like Tarantino knows rhythm and he
knows how to build and and you know
crescendo and then you know rebuild and
stuff like that you know tension and
rhythm and all that but you know we did
just leave this an hour ago and it's a
dense movie so I don't know where this
is gonna fall in terms of that favorites
but that's what I really like about this
particular Tarantino flick I feel like
he's really evolved as a filmmaker like
behind the camera his writing has always
been [ __ ] Incredibles directing has
always been a wonderful finding but yeah
it's it's more solid this film along
with the script of course are you gonna
feel those moments where you're like
that's Tarantino right there
but unless they're way less a little
less of like like you know if you look
at the mid period films like Kill Bill
and stuff like that you know it's a lot
less of like this is a reference shot
and that's a reference shot and here's
you know a you know filmmaking trope
that we would have seen yeah and I'm
sure there are still tons of them but
they're a little more subtle the hand is
a little more steady you know if you
have less bombastic I felt like I'm
really in this world of what's going on
with these main characters so I like it
it there I like the fact that I never
got pulled out thinking this is like
Tarantino touch here
there it was oh I was always immersed
and I feel like Tarantino has created a
film where people will debate about it
you know like usually you walk out of a
Tarantino film and everyone's like those
awesome people debate Tarantino I mean
not I don't think as much as they're
gonna debate this particular movie from
him because these characters I've seen
everyone talking about it like how they
should feel about the movie I feel like
people will walk out less inclined to
know how they'll feel about it because
there's really no good main character
yeah who is the protagonist at different
points of protagonist or antagonist in
some way if you just sort of watching
this unfold you know yeah and that's the
other thing that you're watching a plan
not go according to plan
like which is and I think Tarantino is
great at doing and I feel like an
element he explored was the element of
mystery yeah and I like seeing
Tarantino's take on that cuz it kinda
reminded me a clue yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's Ari I just had this realization
it's like most most movies we see now
focus on how to make the plan work yeah
and what Tarantino just seems to do
differently than a lot of mainstream
cinema is going here's a plan what do
these people do if the plan doesn't work
most of his movies have that somewhere
you know and then the plans either work
or don't like a glorious bastards as
then yeah woops emails talking about
yeah or or Reservoir Dogs is all about a
plan that doesn't work or Pulp Fiction
has you know bands within it that don't
work and you know you can pretty much
point that in all of them and then you
know whoever your protagonists are you
know succeed to varying degrees but
Reservoir Dogs I feel like those
characters are way easier to establish
why you like them these characters are
much more questionable well cuz yeah cuz
this movie lets you see pretty much
everybody do or confess to doing
something terrible whereas there's
something about you know in American
morality it's like Reservoir Dogs is
about you know a heist gone wrong it's
less of a stretch for us to identify
with like people robbing a jewelry store
than it is to identify with you know
people we're very unsavory these are all
likable guys and they're robbing
jewelry store so it's like we can we can
skip a certain level of chastisement
totally for characters like that yeah I
think the film's totally worth watching
because I would love to see the amount
of different opinions this film has and
yeah yeah which character people felt
was the least bad and stuff because
that's that's a beautiful thing about
this film that it's so violent gritty
nap I get so honors the title yet you're
like [ __ ] does it well it's kind of
how I felt about the Devil's Rejects
like this is a nasty violent film but
it's so committed to what it's doing
yeah I know I wanted to do yeah I love
it when they don't hold back I guess you
could also debate this but the film is
sort of not telling you that you should
like any number of people yes when I
left I was sort of like the only people
I feel like I could probably like or
like meanie
yeah like a couple people like a couple
of the supporting characters who we
don't really get to spend much time with
like those are the only people I would
guess I might be able to like you know
with happy without a pig but but having
them just enhances the story of these
characters as to how disgusting they are
rating time people I give this film four
out of five hateful masturbates I guess
I guess rhymes better people eight
hateful masturbate it is a - it's a
little more syllables yes you know
whatever give your rating I don't know
hate boiling things down into numbers
like cuz I don't know yet like my oddly
enough my least favorite thing to do
when I've left a movie is talk about it
right always me too I don't know I
usually ruminate on it for a long time
before I start speaking about it and
this is again this is such a dense movie
that I don't I don't know what I would
like people expect that out of you cuz I
noticed whenever I'm really impacted
with a film whether it be good or bad
I'm not talking about it I'm like I'm
really just quiet and thinking about it
and the people are always like what's
wrong did you like the movie except you
just started chatting about it oh man I
had an experience of some
depending on the weight of the movie you
know it might take more than yeah go go
see I think this is you know do you like
a Tarantino movie then go see it it's a
three hour Western paranoia flick yeah
with a lot of heavy so on a heavy I
don't know I mean it's very different
from most things we see nowadays so I
was just say to go see it cuz anytime I
try to zero it on a number right now I
don't know if it's the right one so it's
awesome tacular anyway guys listen if
you guys want to subscribe to the
channel you can click this button right
here I'm putting here in front of me now
no came smarter as you can reasons to
GRE dank ass dubs on this channel hosted
by said jer-bear hmm find out what the
play that's are about I want to mention
this again there's a Christmas
announcement video we put out been
getting a lot of submissions for it and
I want more submissions more Veronica
the other day was like can you handle so
many people submitting and I said yes
this is submitter what I'm talking about
in that video yeah I go check it out
yeah I get views on that video now mmm
what'd you do smart marketing direct
them to another video of yours oh well
yeah YouTube creator studio stop